okay hello everybody my name is
markiplier and I'm Colonel back in
Cincinnati I just wanted to make a short
video real quick because I ran out of
free recording stuff so just give you a
little update happy Thanksgiving
everyone the celebrates Thanksgiving and
this buddy if you don't know buddy I
mean I show a lot of pictures of Lucy
that's just because I usually stay in my
mom's house but this is buddy buddy I've
known way way long ago did you or did
you feed your hand with tiny itty three
most adorable would sweetest dog ever
sweeter than Lucy Lucy's a sweet dog but
she just a puppy with dish boy just
wiener puppy so anyway I just wanted to
say been spending time with my family
also I got the cry shirt on I've been
spending time with a lot of fans and
self help Wade move into a new place I
have been able to have a lot of fun with
people and and also I've been circling
World of Warcraft again if you didn't
know I'm I started up a guild on erson
because the game grub support side and
I'm Alliance siding the market beams if
you want to join us whisper anyone if
you play wow if not it's totally fine
I want to wanted just another way to
play with you guys because I don't get
many opportunities and then my moans are
actually a convenient way to get
everyone it was place in one place just
you know after I put out the message
video from last week you know I had a
lot of heartfelt emotions in that one
and just seeing the outpouring of love
from the community was outstanding it
and heartwarming to see and just I'm
truly honored that you guys you know
respect me enough to understand that
want to have something important to say
you know you appreciate it and you not
only appreciate you channel it and send
it out to everybody else who needs to
hear it and I'm so grateful that you
guys you know take this what we do see
because you know we really do have an
opportunity to make a difference that's
what's really really important and
that's why I had that little moment
where I just had to say something yes so
this that's a cliche at this point but
just thank you guys so much for
supporting me and thank you so much for
supporting each other because I mean not
only do you guys pour love to me but you
guys pour love to everyone out there I
saw all across Facebook Tumblr and
Twitter that everyone was talking to
everyone saying how much they needed to
keep going and believing what they
wanted to do people are still trying to
learn dresses artists hi bro I just want
to say thank you for standing up for
each other because that's what really
shows what a community is all about you
know not only just throwing love my way
and I lightweight excess of love coming
my way but showing love to each other
understanding through each other so just
thank you guys again for me anyway I'll
wrap this show thought you'll play with
buddy a bit more he's getting old but
she's don't ramble just so thanks again
everybody so much for watching
thanks bro for filming you're welcome
bye bro bye bye everybody out there as
always that will sue you did you get
Cleo oh boy boy boy my mommy forever